Speaker 1: Last week we had some pretty solid
unemployment numbers or employment numbers.
This week we received pretty shocking and
unexpected new unemployment numbers.
New weekly jobless claims announced this morning
unexpectedly dropped to their lowest since
the start of the pandemic.
Again, for a second week in a row, we were
expecting 610000 people to file new unemployment
claims.
In the past week, we got five hundred and
forty seven thousand.
So we came in more than 10 percent lower than
the expected number of unemployment claims.
That's negative.
From the standpoint of positive, I'm sounding
kind of like Trump, what I mean is when you
are measuring something bad, people losing
jobs coming in low is good.
I tested very positively from the standpoint
of negative.
OK, for context, during the Great Recession
of the 2000s, the high mark for one week job
losses was six hundred and sixty five thousand.
We are now below that number for two weeks
in a row.
And remember that we are 90 percent below
what we were seeing in twenty, twenty, sometimes
six million new jobless claims in a single
week.
We are about 90 percent below that.
So that's all pointing in the right direction
now.
It's not all perfect.
There's no reason to pretend it is.
This is economic for me.
It's not political.
Continuing claims, meaning people who were
already unemployed before this week and are
still unemployed, that came in slightly higher
than expected at about three point six million
people.
That's not great.
We want to keep seeing that go down.
There is still a generally high level of unemployment.
Some states it's really high.
Alaska is an example.
Nevada is an example.
Now, let's just go through our reminder.
The American right wing wants us to think
things are terrible and not improving because
Joe Biden is now president.
So they will, as they always do when a Democrat
is in the White House, say that the normal
unemployment rate doesn't tell us the truth,
the truth trademark.
You need to look instead at the you six.
The you six includes people who are working
part time because they can't find full time
work, people who are discouraged and they've
stopped looking for work, et cetera.
That's fine.
I you know, that's also declining.
The you six spiked to more than twenty two
percent at the start of the pandemic.
It was down to twelve point something when
Trump left.
It's now down to ten point something percent.
The U.S. is always higher than the U3, but
it's declining as well.
And that is a very good thing.
You know, people people often want to call
out one measure or another as misleading for
political reasons, as if it's some kind of
malicious conspiracy.
Each of these indicators is designed to show
something different and to tell us different
things.
You look at more data points and you have
a deeper understanding of what's going on.
No one data point tells you everything.
Look at the U3, which is the unemployment
rate that's often talked about on the news,
but also look at the you six look at wages,
look at new claims, look at consumer confidence
and inflation, which we see typically through
the consumer price index.
Look at the stock market.
It's also a unique situation right now where
there are people who lost jobs completely
due to the pandemic.
They're coming back partially now as businesses
start to reopen, many of those people who
are currently back part time, but they used
to be full time.
They will go back to being full time eventually.
Not all, but many will.
There are some areas and industries that actually
need more people now than they did before
the pandemic, because there are some industries
on hiring sprees trying to resolve the supply
chain issues that were exposed by the pandemic.
Remember that in March, April, May of twenty
twenty, there are really examples or anecdotes
of everything for people who want to find
them.
But the big picture is that things are improving.
Not surprisingly, and as we said before, the
biggest indicators of how things will go in
the coming weeks are not economic numbers.
They are medical numbers.
When cases trend down and deaths trend down,
the economic indicators are likely and and
reasonably expected to improve.
Massachusetts is now down to just ten covid
deaths a day.
That is the lowest number since March of twenty
twenty.
Understand the scope of that.
Massachusetts now has reduced daily covid
deaths to a number we haven't seen since faught
thirteen, fourteen months ago.
That is a really good economic indicator,
even though it's not an economic indicator,
it's actually a medical indicator.
So we know what we have to do.
We see the numbers starting to improve.
Now it's a question of are people going to
get vaccinated?
It would not be surprising.
I was reading a piece from Doctor Dr. Ashish
Shah, or I believe his name is from Brown
University yesterday.
He is saying.
Contagion outdoors is so low, we believe maybe
one in a thousand cases are transmitted outdoors
that things are looking good enough that we
could probably do away with any outdoor masking
mandate states that still have them relatively
soon.
These these bits of good news are going to
accelerate the more quickly that cases and
deaths go down, which is, of course, driven
by vaccinations going up.
Let me know what's going on in your state.
Are you still wearing masks indoors?
Outdoors, what's going on?
People in the audience living in all sorts
of different situations.
Let me know on Twitter where you can find
me at Pakman.
We will take a break.
And we have so many things to discuss coming
up.
We are now at risk of running out of membership's.
There has been a run on membership's at join
Pakman Dotcom, sort of like a bank run when
everybody wants to pull their cash out.
People just going crazy.
It's almost like Black Friday out.
There are people getting these memberships
you can get yours at.
Join Pakman Dotcom, the best way to directly
support The David Pakman Show and of course,
discounts.
We are handing them out with absolutely no
means testing.
That's the way I like to do it.
Take a discount if you want discounts for
everyone.
Coupon code better.
Twenty one that will chop the price of a membership
on my website dramatically